she had to go wash some good uniform
some [ __ ] and she still had her uniform
de guerrilla
not knowing how to swim she said [ __ ]
this jumps in
wakes up
washed up on shore
with the guerrilla uniform
as to what town bro
guess who was in charge of that town who
the military that's crazy so bro imagine
they see the enemy bro where it's on
site it's death in five four three two
one what's up everybody welcome to
another episode of the genius brain
podcast cheers brother hey cheers
a very uh special guest today we got
sergi actually how do you say your
[ __ ] last name
i already expected this too
um so it's betancourt betancourt
okay um but in high school and
everywhere else in the us it's benker
bettencourt yeah i was like how the [ __ ]
do you say his last name serge is
actually my barber and the the funny
thing is is like
i had a barber before and uh this [ __ ]
this [ __ ] well just started like
ghosting me for a [ __ ] second
and i think i know what happened too
like he [ __ ] up my hair once right
and i'm like whatever you know people
all make mistakes and i was just like ah
whatever's this is kind of [ __ ] up
whatever and i kind of left and then he
just kind of started like being a little
weird about it and [ __ ] i'm like bro you
you [ __ ] up like what did he do he uh
the [ __ ] was hella and he actually cut
in too deep on one side and so i'm like
oh [ __ ] and i'm not really tripping like
whatever hair grows back it doesn't
really matter but i did mention to him
i'm like
you [ __ ] cut hella deep right here
guy
i wonder what happened i don't know
maybe he took it personally or whatever
but yeah yeah oh because you actually
mentioned it yeah uh dude some barbers
will
will get salty man yeah crazy and his
issue too was that he would always take
super long on his on my cuts because he
was so busy just [ __ ] you know
chatting it up with everybody else and
it would be like a two-hour cut and i'm
like bro i got places to go yeah
yes bro i've seen i've seen people bro
being in the barber game now for like
eight years or so and like actually
having like a few years in a shop
i see people going to the back like to
eat a sandwich
people taking smoke breaks bro and i'm
just like
yo
dinner with their mom yeah that likes a
date to b2 or something you know so yeah
that's a big one bro that's a big one
well it was interesting because like i
actually i actually met sergio through
somebody who was a fan who actually took
over my lease for my apartment
maverick right and then maverick was the
one that actually mentioned you he goes
yo my homie cuts hair give him a chance
i was like so sick what the [ __ ] do i
have to lose right that guy he he came
through for me the first haircut i did
for him was at the dorms like in the
dorm bathroom of cal poly oh wow i had
seen his hair at a party and i was like
yo this guy's hair is fresh turns out he
was getting haircuts from this this
crazy barber in l.a called julius caesar
and what's even trippier is he was going
to where i'm cutting now
oh
it's vince the barber the guy who cuts
tim yeah his studio grey mat i think it
was yeah it was gray matter was in that
studio space
and i had mentioned like yo your hair is
fresh let me cut it up ends up switching
to me
linking to you i move into that same
spot tim walks in and he's like
i've been here before yeah that was the
same place bro oh that's [ __ ] crazy
crazy but maverick hey that's my boy he
came through with that well it's
interesting too because you said you
started cutting hair uh through youtube
right dude which is so [ __ ] crazy man
like whenever i hear somebody who gets
skills through
through youtube it blows my mind because
when i was younger everything was
through trade right so if you if you
were learning to cut hair
and i mean obviously you would go to
barber school but before that there
weren't any videos online for us to
learn how to do fades or nothing so when
i started it was almost the same way
but it was potato quality youtube videos
all right
it was this guy taking his randy using
the machine that i didn't want to use so
i
i'm not gonna lie bro people think i'm
like i took hella classes and [ __ ] dude
i watched six months of youtube videos
and just winged it and i just i've been
wigging it since bro and it's been like
it's been a blessing especially like
recently i don't know if you saw i was
at a friend's birthday party pool party
that was the guy who let me chop his
hair destroy his hair six months senior
year really
[ __ ] homie bro
and i would be using his dad's clippers
and i'd be like doing the zero line
watching the video
opening the guard
going up
same thing turns out the lever was was
not um sturdy so it closed back up so
i'll go zero open up to do a half back
to zero oh my god [ __ ] like that and i
would just be watching this one dude
cake in his randy so shout out to that
guy
potato quality videos so but now
the game's changing youtube like you
were saying bro it's it's crazy yeah
like so many people too like growing up
you know when you used to get your hair
cut like getting your hair cut or just
like faded up was was everything right
yeah like it would set your mood for the
[ __ ] week if your [ __ ] haircut was
[ __ ] up it would ruin your whole week
and like your permanent shirt all the
homies would try to learn how to cut
their hair by themselves right i would
try to do it myself but then i was like
[ __ ] i'll just get my mom to cut my
hair yeah because i don't give a [ __ ]
but then i was so ticklish my mom used
to slap me upside my head because i
would move so yeah yeah so every time i
hated getting a haircut i was
traumatized i was like i don't like
[ __ ] haircuts because every time i
would move my mom would [ __ ] slap me
like the [ __ ] she just let the [ __ ] out
of me i used to get like seven dollar
haircuts too after that same because it
was so cheap but then seven dollar
haircuts are seven dollar haircuts
my my pops would take me to the seven
dollar bar lady she would give me a one
on top or on the mid on the sides and a
three on top no fade bro i hated haircut
i used to i don't know i showed you i
used to have a little like afro yeah and
i
when i got into the barber game
was literally what i was cutting other
people i didn't know bro so i discovered
it still having ugly hair that's why i
like barely ever have like nice haircuts
bro and people are like i used to do
straight up like a one and then i'd do
like a three on top and i just leave
this oh and it's just
it was the worst i hated it i was so
dude they're making money bro one and
three yeah a few minutes boom seven
bucks we'd be in and out like 20 minutes
just quick bro quick and so they would
just do it like the repetition so like
for them they could get us out in 20
minutes each sometimes even faster
fosters themselves yeah no faith exactly
that i remember like i was like [ __ ] it
let me just go back to getting like
fades again and it's hard to go back and
a lot of people don't understand like
salon cuts versus barber cuts are two
different things right and i always tell
like young men
um like some of the basic stuff right
especially when it comes to like looking
good dressing nice or whatever there's a
couple of basics it's like have some
good jeans have a decent pair of shoes
and always get a nice haircut yeah
that's it some dudes can just rock the
most basic clothing but as long as their
fate is super nice and their shoes are
clean that's all you need
right and a lot of people do they come
out a little scrubby and they don't
understand it's because your [ __ ]
haircut's black right and so what i
always say like barbers always do they
do god's work
like it makes you a different man when
pandemic happened we saw the world
crumble bro yeah everybody missed their
barbers we we were [ __ ] desolate
we're like we need somebody to touch up
everybody started trying to cut in their
hair again i loved it i loved it bro
bro it changed the game for us yeah
because even though we're supposed to be
recession proof and that was out the
door [ __ ] i was like oh yeah i'll
never lose work pandemic happens that
shitty but
the appreciation dude
people were like hitting me up like bro
i love you
dude you saw what i look like i look
like a japanese lesbian bro oh
my god that's right
where i did the side of your hair and
you had a mullet yeah
my hair was crazy dude i had look at the
japanese [ __ ] hair on the side
bro
yes you had the little curl yeah i was
like yo somebody [ __ ] somebody give
me a haircut dude
dude i was
my sister was so i mean it was scary you
know first coat like we thought everyone
was gonna die yeah we were using gloves
at the gas station all that [ __ ] which
we probably should do still because
[ __ ] gas station pump but
like dude my sister was like no haircuts
out of respect it is what it is like my
clients suffered for three solid months
before i did a haircut dude it was a
long ass time i didn't have a haircut
forever the barbers in the garage were
charging a hundred dollars though damn
so they up-priced that [ __ ] because they
they're risking their lives they're
risking their lives yeah yeah they're
down bro i don't know that's crazy i
would i might have done it had it not
been for me like respecting my sister
because i was living with her at the
time i would have taken the chance i've
been like i need a [ __ ] haircut
i was like
hit you up it's like hey bro i know it's
covered in [ __ ] i'll double wear this
mask i'm fine just somebody give me a
haircut oh my god you saw a hazmat suit
yeah i don't give a [ __ ] i'll wear
everything down and i'll just make sure
i'll just [ __ ] leave my hair out and
you would just favorite with a little
plastic tape everywhere
but it was weird though because even
mario didn't want me to get a haircut or
whatever and it's funny how like these
things that are you know it's our luxury
to get a haircut becomes a huge part of
our identity and necessity because we
don't realize like how much we
are like really because i really don't
give a [ __ ] about what i look like but i
do give a [ __ ] about my haircut yo
and it's like and it's not even like
for others some people don't even give a
[ __ ] about other people looking at them
it's just the feeling of like having
like weightlessness
yes bro the weightlessness feeling the
feeling of the pillow oh yes oh we're
all a cold pillow after a fade man dog i
just don't look good with long hair bro
like i just don't look good with it
honestly that's like my all my asian
homie stories yeah it's it's because of
how straight it grows yeah it's rough
it's rough like unless i'm gonna like be
a sumo like it's not gonna happen dude
like i can't [ __ ] do it man
but i won't let you get some more bro
we're gonna we're gonna hit him
hey but interestingly enough like you
know sergio has a very interesting story
specifically with his family so this was
cutting up my hair and this one just
starts going into this story about how
his family came here to this country
like it's like a most like a casual
common story and i'm sitting here
thinking what the [ __ ] is this
you know and i always talk about you
know especially because um i have a
podcast where we kind of go over what we
talk about what's happening out in
afghanistan and i think people in this
country they don't realize how fortunate
they are to live here bro right and
absolutely no matter how many times like
even my personal i'm from south korea
right so i'm not from
like
vietnam or laos like coming from these
like secret wars or anything else like
that but the immigrant story is
something that's very important for
people to hear because a lot of people
they say they understand why they're so
appreciative of of this country they'll
wear they'll wave the american flag they
say i love this country but in terms of
their behavior and how they portray it i
don't think they really understand how
great this country is to live right so
when we had this idea of like our
freedoms being taken away people kind of
just
they don't understand like what it
really means that's why i always say
like immigrants are the ones that really
do love this country the most because of
where we came from and what we had to go
through we we know
how ruthless you want to tilt the mic
down a little bit yeah we we know how
ruthless the
the world could be outside of like this
like
palace walls or some [ __ ] bro like even
though we do have our own problems in
this country
you could do anything you want yeah you
could do
anything you want if you really like set
yourself to it and that's something that
other countries don't have whether it be
like uh a government like coming through
and like like like my armenian homies
told me like oh their government's gonna
come and tax you on your business that's
why they want to open businesses here or
like in colombia like
like like the story i was telling you la
guerrilla
for the farmers they're supposed to be
for the farmers bro they go in and they
take your [ __ ] they're extorting
extortion doesn't really happen here as
much
and that's like something we don't get
like it goes deep it goes deep like
extortion here is on the down low right
over there it's right in front of you
right
and you can skip it what are you going
to [ __ ] know about it right there's
there's mafia drug lord [ __ ] and then
there's the government right and then
and then no no wait and there's la
guerrilla bro which is i'm i'm gonna
explain to you like with my grandma
who would you want yeah just start
telling the story man just because i
heard a little snip of it of it and i i
thought i was watching a [ __ ] movie
okay
so it's it's it's a rough story for my
family just because it's sad but i
really want to share it because i think
it's so important to keep it alive
because my grandma was a g like a triple
og bro yeah my grandma uh ana melba rios
she was like born i think she was born
in uh in the 30s in 37 right so she was
born in uh manisales which is caldas
which is part of a
cafetero so it's like where all the
coffee comes from like if you ever go to
columbia you have to go to
cafetero
they have a amusement park of coffee oh
[ __ ] it's like a big deal colombians are
known for coffee like that is a thing so
she was born into like a farmer uh into
a farmer's uh
family and my great-grandfather he
he was like a con colonizer like they
will go
and they like go to a part of the jungle
tear it all down
set up a farm that's how they did it
back then so he goes sets up his farm
has my grandma
um she's the second oldest the
she the first two were girls um it was
like a family of nine or something
they would always be patrolled by a
thing called la guerrilla
specifically was it was las farc which
stands for fuerstas armadas
revolucionarias de colombia
which is funny because bro they took
fuertel's armadas colombianas which is
like
they say [ __ ]
so they take
which is like government conservatives
yeah whatever there's conservatives and
liberals in um in colombia those are the
parties you're either conservative
liberal and then there's a spark which
is super left
and they are supposed to be for the
people for the farmland blah blah blah
this is that [ __ ] bro it's like it
they they ended up
maybe they started like a lot of things
start that way but you know how it goes
with money power whatever they ended up
in narcotraffico they ended up like drug
dealing extorting doing some heinous
[ __ ] bro
this podcast is brought to you by better
help my friends you guys know i have
been talking about better health for
quite a while and is one of the best
things i've ever done in my life mental
health is super important and we've all
been cooped up tense and honestly we
know the importance of our mental health
so stop pushing your emotions aside and
get to it baby better help will assess
your needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist no this
is not a gimmick this isn't some random
person you don't have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room and you can
message your counselor at any time while
setting up weekly video phone sessions
it's super convenient and more
importantly allows you to be safe and
comfortable in your own environment i
know that helps me out a lot because
your boy deals with a lot of social
anxiety and i don't want to deal with
people all the time so if i could do it
on my own time over the phone it makes
it so much easier and better for me so
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
and geniusbrainlisteners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
genius so visit betterhelp.com
genius get that 10 off and work on that
mental health my friends
so they would just walk freely through
the farmer's lands right so my my
grandma she would just be chilling
whatever
and in comes la guerrilla to
her dad like
kill that [ __ ] cow
and feed all of us tell your [ __ ] to
feed all of us bro
so get all these kids to start cooking
we want a fresh meal so they'd have to
lose a cow i don't know how much cows
are yeah [ __ ] whatever and they'd
have to do as told because they'll kill
you
simple as that
so first that was the first few
encounters and it was you walk like you
said you walk freely whatever
so
this i i didn't tell you this is so
[ __ ] up bro i finally found out
my grand my great grandfather had a like
basically adopted a kid
and they would call him perro loco
crazy dog yeah so pero loco was like a
worker and he became part of the family
but because la guerrilla i was around
how it happened so much bro it's just
like a little brainwashing here little
brainwashing there kind of straight off
the wrong path
he comes back and my and my
great-grandfather at the time as a
farmer you don't say what you believe in
you don't say what politics i what
political side or whatever even though
like my family
like them i'm pretty sure they're more
liberal leaning
this guy
would not say anything
and so the the the guerrilla goes
yo pero loco
are you a conservative
are you are you siding with i forgot the
word but they'd call him like some like
like taunt
and for initiation to show him how real
he was
he's like yeah
that guy doesn't want to say like what
party he's at let's go there
and he's like
all right let's go to my great
grandfather
so my grandma
i think at this moment my my my
grandma's older sister this the sec the
actual head of the family he was married
at 13. oh my god okay how it goes eight
it's like the 30s you know so married at
13 off with another family so my grandma
was like the head he's like what the
[ __ ] sees her dad get taken away she had
climbs to go see bro
pero loco
kneeled my great-grandfather down shot
him in the head execution style what the
[ __ ] [ __ ]
as like an initiation to prove his
loyalty to the las farc
they come back burn down the farm so my
grandma and or my great grandma now a
widow takes all the kids let's [ __ ]
go
goes does it all over again
comes through
my grandma now 10 years old
bro
and and mind you
has
minimal education
so another thing i didn't tell you
at the time women didn't get expected to
be like put through school whatever my
great-grandmother wanted them to be a
little educated so her and her older
sister would trade off days that they
could go to school behind my
great-grandfather's back
they would hide a uniform under their
bed like lay it like super flat whatever
every day come back make it in time to
go bring out the dinner
that they these my great grandfather
thought they were cooking so she got
about two years of education in wow 10
years old
guerrilla comes to the new settlement
it's like all right you're ten let's go
and no one could do [ __ ] because they'll
kill anyone who says otherwise
now my great my grandmother
poor poor girl like she's a little girl
bro ten years old like i was [ __ ]
playing we're all playing you know like
yeah instead gets taken off to agueria
jungle straight
jungle bro
gets taught for a year on guerrilla
warfare this that blah
blah 10 year old little girl bro
bro
blah
anyone anyone that's like of age it's
like it's like what goes on like uganda
and [ __ ] yeah
same [ __ ] bro so then my poor
grandmother like gets sent off to
to go off and wash something and uh
summa pass was the
rio it was a river okay
my grandma would say that she couldn't
see the other side of this river and she
had to go wash some uniform some [ __ ]
and she still had her uniform the
guerrilla
not knowing how to swim she said [ __ ]
this jumps in
wakes up
washed up on shore
with the guerrilla uniform guess to what
town bro
guess who was in charge of that town who
the military that's crazy so bro imagine
they see the enemy bro where it's on
site it's death you're getting executed
the girls in legeria are getting like
raped then killed vice versa they're
both boy
they're literally boys clubs where they
don't get to see any women so women bro
get [ __ ] with even more yeah she gets
washed up and
think [ __ ] god whatever bro
she gets found by this lady named uh
senora virginia
and she's like what the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] takes her shoes just wash the
bomb short takes her
hydra under her bed
and it's like oh my god what am i gonna
do
like what am i gonna do i have the enemy
under the bed yeah not knowing my
grandma thank dude it's so it's so
clutch like she could have got killed
instantly whatever killed raped
everything all of the above
gets put
when she's not under the bed she gets
put in a wooden trunk
she's a wooden trunk bro
and she and and senora virginia is like
what do i do what do i do what do i do
days go by days go by she like drops off
maybe some bread
she's just chilling in her like uniform
probably like you know like it's not
sanitary she's been in there how many
days and bro she was so tiny because my
grandma at the height at the peak of her
adulthood she was four like ten or four
or nine yeah so she was even a smaller
little girl
in this tiny wooden trunk
the the military would come by and stab
at [ __ ]
and she would see just because they knew
dude no
hiding
the enemy
it was like a war but it's still a war
still deep bro no one knows about as far
they all hear about like the narcos
whatever i mean they kind of go hand in
hand now but dude it's deep so the
military's stabbing at things my grandma
didn't get [ __ ] stabbed thankfully
whatever
and then the whole time listening out of
18 is like how am i going to bless this
like this little baby girl like she
doesn't deserve this she knows that she
got recruited she doesn't want her dead
so she like starts kind of like mingling
with like a general
and she's like
we need to save this little girl she
admits it which is like a death sentence
bro yeah
but the general for whatever [ __ ]
reasons like yeah i i agree
and
it goes formulates a plan
put her in this potato sack
we're gonna go to a military base she
has to stay completely still so they get
her potato sack pretend like she's
bagged potatoes
puts it on the military plane the
military helicopter
flies are over to bogota which is the
capital but like the rural parts bro
brings the helicopter down just throws
the sack tips
my grandma's alive
she goes and she said that she was
[ __ ] starving for like
ever just walking and that was like the
only option it's like the option it's
like the best thing that's like the best
thing yes and that's so shitty bro
that's it [ __ ] it hurts bro it's like
sad you know but like nonetheless she
goes
walks walks
aimlessly ends up at a [ __ ] house
and it's like
i think it was like
i don't know what i think i think it was
like
pre i i don't remember it was like a
priest's house or it was like some house
where they're like she's like yeah i'm
hungry oh bet put on this apron start
cleaning start cooking we'll give you
food they would give her the scraps with
the dogs and be like sleep there too so
she would have to sleep and eat with
dogs bro as a [ __ ] like 11 year old
girl or 10 year old girl god damn bro
she said that she would love these dogs
because they would just keep her warm
like the werewolves would take in the
boy you know like that story or whatever
the wolf's taking the boy
that's her [ __ ] bro she would literally
sleep with dogs to stay warm and these
dogs would probably be like whatever
like
shepherd dogs whatever so they're
probably bigger than her so it was like
it's crazy they like kept her going she
would eat scraps bro with their hands
and [ __ ]
literally just a child but eventually
she would just be like living there
doing that for a while and then out in
um la plaza
i don't know some plaza in in in bogota
she was able or she was able to like
meet some some friends some girls when
she was older i think it went on first
so i don't know like timelines but it
went on for like a bit
she was already older at this point
and she met these girls that were like
yo we could get you work in this
construction business and so she had to
go
and she would clean the outside and and
my my family they don't speak english
much so they would tell me that where is
granito
which i think when i looked it up like
it's it's it's like it's some sort of
material that they put on the outside of
buildings that had like little like
shards of glass and like okay other [ __ ]
and they would have to like scrub it
down or some [ __ ] um that now we would
just use power tools for but dude
apparently her hands would just be
leaking blood day in day out just
grinding [ __ ]
trying to survive whatever
and the the owner of the construction
company
like took a liking to her so she's like
okay i'm gonna move you in towards just
final cleaning of the properties before
we turn them over to the owner or
whatever so she was like oh [ __ ] yeah
like finally so she would just like
clean up after all the construction was
done and this owner ended up becoming my
grandfather so
wow bro 20 years older bro like that's
some like old
yeah 50 60 [ __ ] but this man 20 years
older born in like 1917.
um six foot like seven or some crazy
[ __ ] with my little girl she anyway he's
like four foot ten women bro it's weird
yeah
anyway
dude she gets pregnant
right
worst part is bro my grandma didn't have
sex ed they didn't have none of that
that we had you know yeah she didn't
even know she could get pregnant bro
apparently oh my god dude think about it
she's a little girl in her head she left
she got two years of education
literally
learned how to add subtract
barely read and write
and that was it that's all the education
she had
so she did she technically mentally is
like still a kid a little younger so
she's like holy [ __ ] i haven't [ __ ]
had a kid
that goes on
bro shh
she didn't even know that that women
lactate bro
they didn't know so that [ __ ] like
caused some problems with her chest she
had to go into surgeries bro
[ __ ] like that she's like what the [ __ ]
is going on
but finally when she's about to finish
gets pregnant again that's my mom
so my first the first older sister was
like a year older than my mom she was um
she passed away before i was born she
was um from like some liver problems
whatever so the next one up is my mom
so now she has two little girls bro
she's like what the [ __ ] like i can't
work there's no and like he would
he would be like there to give maybe
i think i think he would give her like
maybe like grocery money
but she
discovered like how i like you know how
it came up on art
bro
she discovered [ __ ] knitting and
sewing
and just
out self-taught
blew up in sewing and knitting and she
started
sewing for all the prostitutes
what the [ __ ]
all this i just found out too bro i'm on
the same boat what the [ __ ] was she
selling them bro
don't [ __ ] know you already know what
it is
because they would have leftover fabric
so probably some skippy [ __ ] yeah
but the leftover fabric it was custom to
be like do you want your leftover fabric
they were balling apparently bro so
they're like you have little girls
that's how she would make my my my
aunt's clothing bro with leftover
fabrics from the prostitutes she would
sew for
and she was making some bread bro
because they had money yeah like
so my grandfather i think he thought
that she was like getting money from
other people but she was just hustling
bro yeah she's a gangster bro
but he would just give her enough to pay
for like
food yeah so she's like kind of bitter
whatever but still
going along um and and dude she just
like self-taught learned how to like
make like with like some like clay
sculptures bro and she would make her
what she was known for
was mini miniature roses any flower you
could think of little angels she would
make anything with sco have you seen the
sculpture in my place yeah big werewolf
bust makes sense bro
she's
sculptor self-taught painter starts
painting on clothing
that's what she would do bro because she
needed to be at home to rape because she
was so determined to help my
my um my aunts
be
one step above her like 10 steps above
her life you know so
and my and my my grandpa like he would i
could truly say he wasn't the greatest
man
because dude he would
he had money bro
he was a business owner he was
successful
and he would be like embarrassed of that
side i'm pretty sure he was talking to
other people like that's a fact he had
other family a lot of a lot of older
guys did that back in the day
so he had another family this was like
the the accident or where i don't know
but he when he would come back
um
he would like apparently like be like
the dinner table with my mom and my aunt
and they'd be eating with their hands
and he'd be on the table being like
you're like an animal oh wow bro but
what does my grandma know she doesn't
know [ __ ] better yeah so
like she was just so determined to like
beat the stereotype that like
that that he already like you're stupid
you're this you're that like you're
uneducated blah blah blah like [ __ ] that
she was a genius bro because with
first and second grade like education or
whatever my mom swears that she would
help them with their homework
until they were like sixth seventh
graders bro wow like how the [ __ ] you
gotta learn that [ __ ] like you don't
[ __ ] read the text but like [ __ ] i
could barely read but that's
she's a gangster bro like when i say it
like she's a genius
imagine if she was formally educated
imagine
who knows but all i know is that i
respect her so deeply for this bro she
would she would do anything for them she
would
bro she put them in a private catholic
school being broke
by doing cutting corners like oh you
need a uniform bring bring bring your
friend's uniform
look at it sew up their own uniform to
look exactly like
[ __ ] like that bro she put them through
a private school and grandpa would never
help and my grandpa would never help he
would come back and my my grandma would
be like this is kind of towards the end
of like their relationship um my my mom
told me that my grandpa would come home
and he'd have pantyhose inside of his
bag and he'd have like all his dirty
clothes so my grandma would always do
that [ __ ] and then one day he calling
her like uneducated or calling her like
uh um
um belittling her
is the word um
she said [ __ ] it and she like
pulled out the pantyhose put it on top
didn't do [ __ ] for him
and she went to the mirror
doing her hair
whatever and he's like
what the [ __ ] are you doing and then
he's like
yo don't make me hit you
because one of my flicks will knock you
out for three days
and my grandma's
doing her like hair in the mirror goes
man if you knock me out for three days
you better hope it actually kills me
because i'll [ __ ] kill you
oh
[ __ ] dude and dude this guy got up to
here he's like
got up to hit her my grandma grabs a
bottle bro and she's like i will kill
you wow
homeboy dipped
wow
bro bro like she's
i told you about she would def she would
be sleeping in that house in in in la
dorada
with a revolver under her pillow just
kicking i told you about this [ __ ]
crazy because people try to break in
yeah bro one time they try to break in
all she had to do is clock [ __ ] that
[ __ ] done they're not gonna [ __ ] them
why are they gonna get shot you know go
break it to the next house bro she was
such a g dude
that's crazy though i like yeah i'm so
i'm so amazed by her man melba
me me abuelita melvita i would call her
and she'll call me her te ronda zuka
like my little bag of sugar that's so
crazy yeah what's what's rough though is
um all right i'll continue so
after that
um
apparently i don't know how how factual
this is a doctor she had migraines the
doctor's like yo you have to have
another kid to get rid of this
which is so weird
so she goes and she's like i'm not gonna
have a kid with another man
she's like hey come back how he gets
pregnant peace out like yeah oh my god
that's so [ __ ] so funny it's so funny
and she's like i don't [ __ ] need you
by the way but like i just want these
migraines gone and that's my aunt um
pakiko which is the artist she's
so talented bro so she's so lit man
she's such a good person but pakiko
apparently this guy she's like hey you
have to come with me
because you have to prove that this is
your daughter so it could be your same
last name
and if you don't i'm going to switch all
their last names because i'm not having
three girls with different last names so
this guy came and he found out the
gender because he looked at the name he
didn't even give a [ __ ] bro
so kind of a scumbag
pretty scummy but
anyway um he
that was the end of that
my grandma raises them um at some point
like my
my aunt um my first aunt passes away
from that liver thing whatever um this
point like my mom's of age she's going
to school
meets my father whatever they they're in
their master's programs they're both
they pull that master bro they're really
my my parents are educated like
i i'm very proud of them anyway
during that time get pregnant with my
sister then they have me
during that whole time this guy has like
a family with someone else my
grandfather and he buys a a platano farm
so like um
plant plantation plantain farm yeah so
and on the magdalena
buys this big farm and of course come
back la guerrilla oh look at the farm
goes in damn it and they try to extort
so they tell the headed farmer
like yo
make sure this guy pays us and he
regulates the message and my
grandfather's i ain't paying [ __ ]
so then
lageria is like what's his schedule the
farmer caves tells them when my [ __ ] my
grandpa's gonna be there
and the teacher that like was around the
area or something heard
and she's like
oh my god
they're gonna come kill you tonight you
have to dip
and so he literally laid on a canoe
in the magdalena which is another big
river
and didn't get up while they were like
all around him and the canoe just
drifted away drifted away and that's how
he escaped the farm
and then
the head farmer gets coerced to be like
oh hit him up and be like hey
i'll buy your farm blah blah blah to
then bring him back so they could murk
him you know kill him
and the teacher goes it's set up blah
blah blah don't do it
teacher gets hung and he like hears
about like the teacher just being hung
on his farm so this guy goes yes
yes bro like they're savage bro and
they're still around
they're still around the jungles of
colombia this the teacher was a woman or
a woman poor woman i know bro imagine
and it's all because of the head fire i
don't know so
i i kind of trip out about talking about
this beast like i get still around so
hopefully they don't watch genius
i mean there's documentaries about them
yeah this is true
so
fast forward to my my parents um
so this guy lost his farm
zero lost hella money probably yeah
anyway fast forward my parents they're
doing their thing
successful in their country whatever
um during this time there's still chaos
pieces that narcos came about um in the
80s
and so they're like ah this country's
like whatever's whatever and
i think it was my dad got into like a a
fender bender and my dad's like kind of
fresh bro i'm not driving that car to
work yeah yeah say let me borrow your
car to my mom just take the day off so
my mom's like okay i'll take the day off
and she um she went
walk she's like ah my mom loves to be
active she's she's such my mom is
equally as crazy as my grandmother okay
my mom's a g but yeah she's like i'm
gonna take the baby i'm gonna walk
however many miles whatever to the bank
goes and she said that she was crossing
this crazy intersection four cars this
way four cars this way um
and she like crosses across his busy ass
damn near highway
and as she's about to step on the curb
she sees like these sketchy the sketchy
couple
and then she sees like a foot behind
like a tree
and as she's about a step she's like i
got it in a baby like grab the baby so
she's like [ __ ] i'm not they're not
taking my kid jumps backwards into
moving traffic bro
because it causes like all this chaos
sees a taxi gets in the front seat of
like a current taxi ride
get the [ __ ] out get the [ __ ] out she's
like what is happening
she's like we have to leave this country
and she thinks that it was people trying
to
get something on my grandpa to sign over
the deed or how to make it official
something like that and they're like yo
we're done
like we need a dip later on find out one
of his other sons one of my my half
uncles or whatever it would be got
killed like as like a part of yeah like
that guy got killed
so it was just like they wanted this man
bro because no one did they ever get to
your grandpa no he died peacefully at
like 90 something jesus yeah but um
it pushed us to like come to this
country because that [ __ ] was not it you
know and it's [ __ ] my grandfather's
fault whatever i mean he was standing up
for what he thought so cool for him but
like yeah everybody else got killed yeah
i'm pretty much so that's how it goes
man and so that
prompted a move and and that's where my
parents resilience comes in it's just
like yo like you guys really left a
whole country where you were successful
yeah to come over here to what to sleep
on the floor bro and my mom unlocked
memories that i [ __ ] forgot like
she's like yeah you don't remember all
of us just sleeping on the floor with
like
using our clothing as blankets and [ __ ]
but isn't that crazy though how that
happens like you you don't
you know you grow up you start getting
new memories new memories new memories
and all this other stuff too and to us
it probably wasn't traumatizing because
we were kids yeah but you just forget
about all the stuff you really do man
but our parents are older they're still
friends
bro it's it's wounds it's wounds bro
it's open wounds so i'm just like
and then like them like damn near
getting to like zero money and then
finding my mom finding the role of cash
in the that was the crazy part man that
was so nice because you told me that
your parents were wealthy back then
right because of the education that they
had bro
and money just comes and goes real quick
when it's converted to u.s you know like
a peso to us nothing yeah over there the
monthly salary is still like two or
three hundred dollars
that's [ __ ] that's [ __ ] up bro yeah
so when how old were they when they came
to the states like in their 30s 40s okay
40
holy [ __ ] and how old were you i was
like three three i think i believe oh so
you're super young baby bro what area
like what what city did you guys move
into perfect oh you guys were in burbank
my mom's like i think i think they had a
friend in burbank okay and so they moved
into burbank and stayed and and when
they got there the friend's like yeah
yeah come
it's gonna be 400 a month to sleep on
that corner
it was like someone they knew bro they
were like [ __ ] with us not really
like helping us at all yeah so they're
like [ __ ] this dude let's go over here
they found like a little like studio
like a room
and that's where we would sleep on the
floor and just like
and but i mean
that whole like
it i mean it builds character yeah yeah
yeah yeah anyway that's where like they
was like coming until like what are we
gonna do like our money's running out my
mom goes
i think she's just crying on the curb
bro and finds a bankroll as somebody has
enough to pay for a rent or something
and that same month
they got work so
the rest is kind of history you know
that's so [ __ ] it's a blessing bro
what's meant to be is meant to be though
you know
yeah i mean it's crazy like you know i
hear this story right like i'm i'm
literally picturing everything going on
you know all the way from your your
great grandmother to your grandmother to
your mom and then next to having you and
then bringing you here right like
i always say to that's why like like we
hear the stories about afghanistan right
this is current right now current bro
you know and i think when people in this
country they complain about their lives
they don't understand how good they have
it like it's hard to explain to somebody
who has has it all in their entire life
bro these people are holding on to
airplanes i know thinking that they're
going to live
to live how do you like how is it could
you even do that is it i don't i think
you'll die you just die i think like the
wind 500 miles 600 miles you can't
breathe you'll die you'll suck you'll
suffocate suffocate and then fall and
like they'd rather risk it to do that
than stay and deal with the talent it's
[ __ ] up it's [ __ ] nuts have you
seen the helicopter [ __ ] now they fly
they've figured out how to fly your
helicopters oh my god they're hanging
people from them
that's [ __ ] crazy dude it's [ __ ] up
that's so nuts it's so [ __ ] you know
like it's it's like when i hear like
everybody's immigrant story it's just
pretty insane right because like i hear
about you know your grandmother and how
like resilient she was because i mean
could you imagine like this 11 year old
girl going to a river to wash clothes
and then she's out of nowhere she goes i
can't live like this [ __ ] this i'm gonna
and by the way those [ __ ] rivers have
creatures in them bro
this isn't like the sacramento [ __ ]
american river spiders are like this big
i know the jungle there's like
crocodiles in the jungle bro yeah [ __ ]
up and she somehow [ __ ] survived
she's washed up bro what's meant to be
meant to be it's [ __ ] crazy
that's increasing crazy bro my grandma
and dude
how the [ __ ] it dude
one day i'ma show you the the [ __ ]
sculpture she would make of the thing
how
dude i swear that she's in me bro she's
like living through me because like
that her and my [ __ ] grandpa on my
dad's side did i tell you that [ __ ]
mm-hmm
i haven't told you no
bro
so i pick up here cutting hair
just
doing my [ __ ] i don't know how i'm doing
it i re like i said i watched six months
of like blurry ass videos and i'm
hooking up the dorms dude
and i'm at dinner
with my parents like i come back from
school i'm like
two years two years into cutting hair
bro i'm like
man
anon some cocky [ __ ] though i'm like man
how am i so good at cutting hair
i'm like who the [ __ ] cuts hair in our
family
and my dad's like dude my dad's so funny
like he's the most calm person just
i don't know
didn't your [ __ ] dad cut hair
well in my dad's defense he like his his
dad passed me like seven from some [ __ ]
okay
bro my grandpa
went
picked up scissors and a comb and cut
the whole pueblo for money that's crazy
so i'm like whoa like surging my
grandfather on one side yeah and then
covet happens i start drawing
i'm like whoa searching my grandma's
artistic side bro i'm like literally
just out here like doubling like my
[ __ ] family heritage like make you
feel
[ __ ] amazing obviously it sucked when
no one like believed it like like yeah
it was a struggle with like going from
like an educate like a super educated
family because both my parents have
masters in economics and [ __ ] like
accounting whatever
business administration
so then being like i would cut here like
dude it was a struggle it was a struggle
so it was shitty but now
now i feel like it makes sense bro it
makes every choice i've made in my life
so far bro
it's
it's it's what it is you know and
it goes back to like like
the brand that i that i'm gonna start or
like like my thing born from rain yeah
i equated like those those months of not
being able to cut hair to a drought
discovering art as the rain and it's
sprouting my studio that's why it's born
from rain my grandmother bro
all that time it's a severe drought
you're a 10 year old girl not having fun
being taken into like
your life is a drought goes and she has
a baby
learns how to knit something she's
passionate about that's the rain yeah
sprouts this family born from rain my
grandfather has all these people that do
this is my dad's family's biggest like
11 kids how am i gonna feed them [ __ ]
severe drought
pick some scissors and comb
born from rain like it makes me feel
so good bro it may i know there's like a
huge resilience in your family right
like everybody seems to have that common
theme is that they take their lemons and
they make lemonade and they make you
have to grow you have to like
i still can't believe your parents have
a master's like in business and
economics and they decided to leave this
country like living in this amazing life
you know you said they had like maids
my sister had like sick ass barbie house
dolls
toys like she was she loved it she tells
me
and she's like tennis court playing
tennis like tutors bro tutors tutors and
class for everything swim she's a beast
swimmer
even though like i didn't really like
have that especially because i was three
yeah but i feel bad for her because she
had it yeah you know so i'm like people
are like damn she had it for i'm like
dude is here where'd you get that [ __ ]
ripped off bro my sister coming to this
country
had to be dude my parents don't speak
english like that bro my sister's a g
too bro i was raised by like strong
women
my dad's like [ __ ] strong male he
like held it down worked like 14 hours a
day every day until he retired whatever
but my [ __ ]
girl the girl side of my family bro they
just are beasts i give so much respect
to my sister bro she raised me she like
she like read every form to ever be
needed in this country for my parents
yeah
it's just damn man resilience it's
definitely within your family because
like even when i hear the story right
you people have to understand like how
terrible was it to live in that country
to live a very comfortable life
financially to come over here convert
the pesos over into freaking american
dollars to maybe survive a few months in
the states having all this i mean that
must have been a shock to your [ __ ]
parents too bro imagine imagine
a bird big white bird
out of all the places you know and they
go there you know they meet up this
friend they're [ __ ] jipping them bro
you know they're extorting them they
have to move somewhere else and all of a
sudden she finds this roll of money out
of nowhere that saves them enough just
until they find a new job [ __ ] crazy
crazy man
i can't imagine what it's like to do
that because even now when i think about
it like could i move to another country
right now and just start up a life like
that i don't know
it's so rough bro but the thing is going
to another country but we have english
yeah that makes it a little easier
because a lot of people know english
yeah
no english
that's [ __ ] insane
out here speak spanish but like damn not
everyone speaks but especially in burma
i know i mean you you took all your own
risks when i first met you you were
cutting at a small barbershop and you
were going uh through an apprenticeship
at the time
i remember when you're working there
you're talking about opening up your own
space dude and then you you [ __ ]
pulled the trigger what it what it was
bro
was
i was convinced that
barbering was my passion right
and
thank covid even though it's like [ __ ]
coven thank covid yeah
i didn't have those three months of
cutting hair
um
which are back-to-back for three months
of being in bed really yeah that's like
[ __ ] up anyway those three months of
not cutting hair i drew that portrait of
sade
perfect
that
literally was the feeling i got from
cutting hair tenfold and i realized like
i was like
oh [ __ ] i don't [ __ ] love cutting
hair i love expressing my myself through
someone's hair i like look at hair
artistically and i realize no i'm trying
to be an artist and that's when i came
back to the shop for like two weeks and
i was telling everyone like yeah man i
would get an art studio and i was like
what the [ __ ] your barber i was like
nah i'm gonna get an art studio barber
studio yeah what it's kovid you just
came from seven months where you out of
seven and a half months you only worked
a month and a half
what the [ __ ] i was like yeah i don't
know i don't and by the way i'm in a new
city
because my clientele is too far away for
me to drive because my ankle is [ __ ]
up
but yeah i'm gonna pull the trigger on
this expensive ass space yeah
but it [ __ ] worked out worked out hey
a year
it's been a [ __ ] year we have been a
year in the studio bro
memories been made bro it's been
evolving that's that's the that's what's
by far you've been cutting my hair for a
year dude bro over a year over a year
now every year and it's like
damn man i remember and and it's like i
remember like yesterday when matt was
like
no pressure bro david's gonna hit you up
i was like dude so
and i did a bad girl and then i want
that girl bro i used to watch you guys
videos you guys are the kings of youtube
yeah you guys bro i love that [ __ ] man i
was just like
oh [ __ ]
it's kind of crazy
i mean like i always say two men like
it's very interesting too with like your
with your personality and how positive
you stay right and it has to be because
of the back story that you know about
your family and where you came from and
it's really hard to explain to people
like trying to get them to understand
like listen if you can count your
blessings your life will be so much
easier
but it's where we're in this world when
you look at twitter we look at all this
other stuff also hair yeah
it's it's so hard it's like how do i
tell how do i tell like a younger
generation like listen you actually have
it really good you have you're the
biggest burden that you have right now
is the burden of choice you have too
much choices you have so much choices
you don't know what the [ __ ] you do yeah
and that's what's stressing you out it's
so interesting which is well put
your burden is everybody else's blessing
blessing bros the dream there are people
who are who are born into trades they're
born as like chattel as property you
have an ability to wake up and choose
what you want to be and you look at that
like oh my god i don't know what to do
which is normal however there are people
who would kill to be in your position i
watched the documentary i forgot i think
it was like in uganda or in africa right
and it's
it's these young women who were just put
into prostitution they're like in these
huts these desolate huts there's flies
everywhere there's [ __ ] everywhere just
garbage and these women since like the
age of like 12 they're prostitutes this
is what they're born into and it's not
to like scare people into doing things
but it's but perspective perspective bro
that's [ __ ] sad man that's
that's real yeah and they have like they
have like venereal diseases and aids for
since they're like you know before they
even hit become a teenager where they
should even [ __ ] be thinking about
that exactly and then
it's it's not to say that people like in
first world countries like wheeling like
we don't have problems but when you kind
of wrap it around this whole thing of
like hey the world that you live in is
this small everywhere else
not
i mean yeah there are other countries
who live as well as we do but there are
other parts that that don't
you got to it really helps you hustle a
little differently ah man you know i
know that that was literally it
we have so many choices
and it literally is like
clouding us and
i mean look at look at your look at your
your grandmother too right like she had
she had one choice either stay
and [ __ ] kill military yeah or jump
into her she's literally
had two
[ __ ] choices
she's at the worst part she's 10. so she
make a choice at 10. she's 10. i can't
believe they put her in a [ __ ] potato
sack dude and she had to stay still
a bad day
doctor [ __ ] threw her out it's like
hey this is your only chance to live i
hope you survive best of luck
peace holy [ __ ] dude and she's just like
walking starving bro starving bro eating
scraps with [ __ ] dogs [ __ ]
out here getting angry
angry
dude i honestly like i get like angry
because like i have friends that get
hanged yeah
i get so angry when [ __ ] get
hangry bro
i get low-key butthurt bro but no one
really knows why but like
dog you're not starving [ __ ] you
have you ate breakfast when my parents
first came to this country like we were
i was like i think i was like two or
three like around your age right so
um
yeah my parents didn't have a lot so my
dad worked as like a mechanic uh he
worked at somebody else's beauty supply
store and my mom was cleaning hotels my
mom didn't speak any english but that
was the only job that she could take and
my doc my dad also did janitorial
services so they had to work multiple
jobs right and then after that um so my
dad first actually to even rewind back
from that my dad first came to the
states going to
houston texas so he lived there because
my aunt was there first and then she
brought my brother my his her brother my
dad over okay and then um when the job
market started drying up or that they
moved to sacramento to start a new life
what year is this around it was when i
was
through so this is
1990 around there so
they're
doing their own thing whatever what not
right and then i didn't see my dad for
the first like two three years of my
life he was there when i was born in the
hospital and then after that he was in
the states trying to build this life in
texas the move that's a sacramento my
brother comes he's five he doesn't speak
any english he had to take esl classes
uh i was like two or three so i kind of
learned how to speak english early on
before everybody else you learn both at
the same time exactly and i remember my
parents store when i first it was weird
because i i remembered it when i saw an
old photo of of our store it was my dad
with one of his friends from korea and i
suddenly i remember i looked at my mom i
was like oh we used to have everything
on cardboard boxes because we couldn't
afford shelves she goes oh you remember
that and i was like yeah it just hit me
right it's just snapseed yeah i remember
all of our products were on the
cardboard boxes that the supplies came
in and then we would just stack all the
stuff on there would they like write the
price we write the prices on the
cardboard boxes and then later on we i
remember when we first got our pricing
gun
and then and you [ __ ] loved it yeah
yes bro
yeah yeah that's so funny that's some
[ __ ] bro that's a [ __ ] little kid
yeah that's like some fun little kid
[ __ ] and then we went we when we first
came in here we used to live uh out in
these uh apartments in the projects and
then from there we lived in a duplex in
this area in sacramento called tem woods
and that was like super [ __ ] hood
there were like simone bloods that live
in those trap houses all around us and
then from there we moved into a rental
house next to the house that we bought
which was next door from our family
friend and that took you know an x
amount of time so we became lower middle
class by the time i was like 14. but
before that we were [ __ ] dirt poor
but the crazy thing is is like when you
have parents who are just as resilient
and they're very grateful you don't
realize how you don't notice you don't
notice bro i thought i was rich
we didn't know we were broke
i knew i was poor when i went to college
bro when you started talking to people
about what they would eat
and you're like i'm like you ate
different things every day yes
your breakfast wasn't the same yeah
dog breakfast legend dinner was the same
for me dude what the [ __ ] are you
talking about bro bro did i tell you the
number one struggle meal that i just
think is so funny because i tell people
and their reaction is great
my mom
would get spaghetti
and she said she found out by some guy
at the store
she would get a can of tuna
she put [ __ ] ketchup and mayo in the
tuna
mix that [ __ ] put on the spaghetti and i
loved it
bro there's hella struggle meals like
that dude all the [ __ ] time oh i love
that [ __ ] i might make it tomorrow just
for the [ __ ] feels
dog so there's a there's like um
i used to eat this [ __ ] all the time
this is back in the day before like
seaweed was popular like seaweed was
like [ __ ] that we would eat so we
couldn't have purified water because
purified water if you get a tank or so
it was hell expensive so we would just
get sink water and we would get roasted
it was this roast it's called poritas so
it's a roasted barley okay and you
probably had it at korean restaurants
but my mom would just make that tea
because we couldn't have purified water
so she would just boil the water with
the tea and we would just drink this
non-caffeinated tea all the time which i
just assumed was always water because
that's we didn't have we couldn't get
water bottles and [ __ ] like that so we
would have that and then my grandma too
she would get the uh the mac and cheese
craft mac and cheese boxes and then it
was that ghetto [ __ ] and then she would
just make ground beef and mix it
together and that was my favorite i
[ __ ] loved that [ __ ] dude
you know and those were those like
treats for us too but it's really just
like those are the treats it's broke
people meals though bruh bro i'll never
forget my grandma so the one time that
she visited the states where we took her
ass to vegas because that's the like
[ __ ] that she would love she just smoked
cigarettes play the gambling machine
whatever
she
put me on to
and i only had it when she was there
she's like oh this is a delicacy
tomato sugar
mix it up
yes yes bro yes tomato and sugar
dog that's so weird why do they my mom
used to do that she was a slice of
[ __ ] tomatoes and put sugar on it
that's delicious mine was like in a cup
mine was in a cup
the korean version the colombian version
shake hand
[Laughter]
bro she would have it on a plate during
the summer time and would sprinkle sugar
on this [ __ ] we would eat this delicious
yeah i [ __ ] love [ __ ] love that
[ __ ] hey i unlocked the memory for you i
saw that like that like [ __ ]
yeah the light bulb get that's [ __ ]
crazy buddy bro that's so funny
let's go
can't get that [ __ ] no michelin star bro
yeah the the tomato sugar [ __ ] snack
man i loved it but that's you know
that's a point too it's like i always
say shout out to my parents like no
matter how much we struggled or whatever
they always made us feel like we had
more than we always needed absolutely so
i always felt like oh this is all
abundance you know because what they had
before that wasn't was not sure because
my dad was broke as [ __ ] my dad had an
education because korean missionaries
came to korea and they gave him an
education my mom was in the shigod area
which was a farm town so she was a farm
town [ __ ] girl okay they didn't
really have much either you know and so
when they moved to the states
my mom was working as a factory worker
for her best friend her so she became
best friends with this lady who's very
very wealthy i can't say their name but
they're very like one of the richest
people in korea but i didn't know that
they were very wealthy right but my mom
did and i would call it harmony
grandma she's not my grandmother though
i didn't know right you're convinced
yeah she's just she's just my mom's best
friend she actually uh passed away rest
in peace all right but
i thought she was my grandmother right
and so i would call her high money all
the time but she used to take care of me
um when my mom was working at the
factory because she was one of her
workers but she would take care of me
and so my mom and her became really
close friends because
um her best friend was from the same
area or the town that my mom was from
and she was a very like harsh but she
married rich to this guy who owned this
huge factory okay so but she's a piece
of [ __ ] like my mom you know but that's
how they would get along because my mom
didn't give a [ __ ] yeah so they would
just curse at each other all the [ __ ]
times sailors like [ __ ] sailors
that's what made them connect for sure
because she's like oh nobody else talks
to me like this like nobody else that
everybody's too scared of me because i'm
the wife of this really rich guy but my
mom didn't give a [ __ ] so they became
really really good friends so when my
mom would work at the factory working on
the line she would take care of me
that's so easy so i would was she was
she significantly older for you to think
it was your homie uh yeah she's like
maybe 10 years older than my mom oh coco
yeah and so she would just always take
care of me the whole time and then uh
this lady is so [ __ ] funny so
because we grew up really poor but they
actually helped my parents out a lot
when we moved to the states they would
send my mom money
did i didn't know this stuff right we're
kids we don't know this stuff so they
would help us out whenever we couldn't
like make rent or whatever yeah so i go
to korea when i'm uh
i think is this when i was 14 this is
when i was 14. okay you're like i'm
chubby and fat right was that your first
time this is my second time going to
korea
i was eight before and when i was 14
like this is how funny this lady is she
is the wife of somebody who's like one
of the richest people in korea right so
we go to this area in korea that's like
this it's like um medieval land but it's
but it's a historical place where they
do it looks like you know those korean
dramas were like an old village okay so
they shoot those stuff here
and so you get to see people make candy
how they used to make it back in the
olden days this is a public park so my
grandma looks at me right she goes
you're really [ __ ] fat right and she
goes your tits are almost as big as mine
and she lifts up her shirt no no
no
no i'm like what bear
no she had a problem but still and my
mom's dying laughing and i'm like yo
what the [ __ ] is with this lady oh and
that's your actually that's my [ __ ]
high money dude and so like this is the
this is the lady that that my mom like
you and grew up with and it's kind of
crazy like that's your fir your second
time meeting here that's my first time
meeting her at that time so i i she took
care of me when i was two one to two
yeah yeah and then i met her when i was
uh eight and then again when i was 14.
and she was just roasting my ass bro
like calling me fat the whole time but
in a very lovely loving way yeah cause
it's still funny like she still
remembers me as this little kid because
she took care of me when i was one or
two yeah i'm her grandson yeah of course
and like my mom said like you were her
favorite and so like i'm [ __ ] like 14
years old and i'm eating at the dinner
table and she would not let me feed
myself she would get the spoon and she'd
be like
and you're just like four all right i
guess all right which is so weird
because like
i um
i mean i only met her a couple of times
but something about that bond that i had
when i was younger when she passed away
i started bawling my eyes i don't know
why
i don't know why but it's because she
took care of my mom she took care of our
family when we really needed it dude
it's a part of yours like being bro it's
your extension to your blood man
and dude like
yeah the the love that you're saying
that she would feed you and sh you're
just like you almost feel like a
stranger but you're doing all this kind
[ __ ] yeah like it makes you feel like so
close
like when i met my grandma dude like i
was just like smothering kisses blah
blah blah bro oh my god like instantly
you know like oh this is my grandmother
when did you meet your grandmother bro i
was a little ass kid yeah it's i was so
young
bro this is how young i was i was still
not wiping my own ass
so i was in the bathroom of our like
little ass like bro i probably met her i
must have been like five yeah or four
something because we're still in that
first spot and
i remember bro i was a lit this is this
is so old holy [ __ ] i was in the
bathroom
finished taking my [ __ ]
and i'm just like
what am i gonna do
no one's home but my grandma yeah not
thinking like oh i could call my grandma
yeah she wiped my mom's ass she wanted
my ass you know yeah so i was just in
the bathroom probably 30 minutes bro
wow before i was like
[Music]
[Laughter]
i was so scared to ask because she was
so foreign to me you know yeah yeah yeah
damn but the good thing is i met um
actually did she come twice or once i
know i met both of my grandmas on one
trip so i was like worlds collide yeah
took their ass to vegas oh brothers
this picture of us in like some hot tub
in vegas and it's so [ __ ] lit how old
is she now well she passed away oh she
passed away she was i think
i think she was probably 82
or 79 it was either one of those two
agents she's like such a crazy [ __ ]
life man dude she was so funny bro she
something was up with her fingers
where
she like her middle finger was like i
don't know if it was short
or what or she had like a long like yeah
she'd flip people off like
[ __ ] you she bro like a sailor
like a sailor bro she cuz like a sailor
i think that's why i i have like kind of
like a
probably like a profound vocabulary but
yeah bro one of the dopest scenes is her
just doing her makeup and her hair bro
saying chills man if if you touch me you
better kill me because i will kill you
how [ __ ] nuts and kept apparently she
kept eye contact when he got up to hit
her and just like grabbed the bottle
she's like i'm gonna kill you i'll
[ __ ] kill you i dare you to and she's
i believe her that's the worst part i
believe her bro she went through what
she's been through she has nothing to
lose
that's crazy man like i'll let you touch
me like even hearing a snippet of before
and hearing the whole story is insane to
me bro like i'm i could picture
everything in my [ __ ] head thank you
yeah bro i i appreciate you inviting me
to actually share this bro i mean i just
want people to hear this stuff because i
could tell my own personal some people
get it right and um there's a lot of
like asian americans kids who listen to
this stuff and they kind of hear their
parents stories
but like it's it's hard for like i said
it's always going to be hard for people
to understand what it is unless you kind
of really go through it
that's why like when i was a kid we used
to go on mission trip missionary trips
to other countries and stuff we would go
to tijuana and you would see how other
other people live and it's like damn
like this is some perspective dude
culture shock it's like this is like
important people everybody else's every
day and you get to walk around and
you're complaining about what toys you
don't have what with this you don't have
and these are all blessings you know
like even having even being able to like
i was talking to
my fiance about this right and this is
when it was like us getting to know each
other a little bit better during
pandemic and when she was going through
a hard time
it was hard for as she's cracking up
outside
literally
it was hard for me to hear her complain
about stuff that she she was going
through a lot of stuff at the time
because pandemic kind of [ __ ] with her
a lot
and she would complain about these small
things and it was hard for me to hear it
it was it was like nails on a chalkboard
because yeah and i was trying to tell
her like give her perspective and then
this is when we were like going through
a lot of problems we talked on the
podcast we were about to split during
pandemic
and i told her one of the hardest things
about it is the fact that i can't be
with somebody who doesn't know how to be
grateful for the things that they have
because i didn't grow up like that like
you can't like i told her like i
remember when i was a kid and or even
like when i first came to la
i everything that i chose on a menu for
food wise was based on what i could
afford
you know and now it's like i could
afford all this stuff and you still
gotta and i still choose portion yeah
yeah you know but the option is there
and i'm like these are the small things
that i'm grateful for that i can go to a
restaurant and look at the menu and
choose what i want to eat
i was like
that's why
sh she knows even this i was like you
never hear me complain about life i
might be irritated about small things
but i never complain about life and i
asked
i was like have you ever heard me
complain about my life she goes no you
haven't i was like because i have
nothing to complain about
i was dirt poor we grew up in the
projects we lived in a duplex and from
that we became lower middle class when i
was you know like 14 years old this
everything else in my life is a bonus
perspective is [ __ ] everything
and it's hard to be around people who
don't see have that same perspective
because it it infuriates you it makes
you mad you know
like i said bro hangry people
i try to i i get it it's kind of you're
hungry but man that [ __ ] pisses me off
sometimes bro because like my
grandmother was starving
yeah yeah i know man perspective bro and
that's a good way to put it man like i
yeah for real yeah man well hey thanks
for coming through the pod man i hope
everybody loved that [ __ ] story uh
tell everybody where they can find you
man get faded up you could find me on
instagram at bfr sergio that's my
personal that's where i'm gonna be doing
a lot of my projects i have a shirt that
i'm going to be putting out pretty soon
that's going to fund a project that's
near and dear to my heart in colombia
this december wherever my grandma's from
i told you so just be
keeping up with that for updates and
then barber wise
right now i'm i'm
pretty busy so i'm not taking
that many people
um it's kind of like an invitation only
but all of your fans that i've taken in
have been [ __ ] dope so if you guys
want a haircut um at bfr studios that's
my business page my portfolio page you
could see the haircuts there see what i
could do i know how to cut asian hair
very well as well yes he does which is
one of those
very it's very hard to find i i try to
be diverse in it um but yeah dm me if
you really want a haircut we can
probably work something out but
appreciate you guys appreciate you
brother
like another haircut without the hair
getting cut i don't know do appreciate
it well you guys can catch genius train
on every thursdays and sundays follow
sergio if he has openings i'm telling
you some of the best cuts you'll ever
have in your life great conversation
just a good person which is why i always
plug his stuff when he started going to
the new studio i started plugging his
[ __ ] because i wanted him to be sexual
and look what's happening man he's
killing it really for real cool we'll
see y'all next time
peace